The joe rogan experience of Decorah.
I did a karate Guy Story to street karate guy.
What happened?
This is a funny story.
Okay.
We're at,
um,
at,
Kimbo has to fight and um,
before the fight would go to a tap out party and those people are there.
And then these guys,
he stuff guys that they're one of us,
I think selling jewelry or something and he was with a bunch of guys and,
and from the guys,
I think he was the toughest guy.
So,
um,
we're talking and of course you know it,
but he didn't know who I was.
So that was the best thing.
And that people were talking about finding a,
suddenly he comes to fourth and he goes,
yeah,
I used to do a karate.
He says,
but not a normal cardiac goes to do street karate.
I go,
wow,
street karate was,
or what is that?
So,
well,
I can tell you one thing that my routine has saved me like six,
seven times.
And I go,
you're a teen.
Yeah,
I got,
okay.
You,
you got to show me their routine.
And you know,
because I would,
I would love to learn.
So the guy comes to me and I actually put us in a movie,
here comes the boom,
you know,
that was a true story.
I an eye,
there's a long story.
But anyway,
yeah.
So the guy comes to me,
he says,
first of all,
I would stand there and an out of the blue,
I will go and eat.
No,
no,
no.
He got his,
God's first with his elbow.
He goes to me,
he does it to me,
disclose,
right,
blah blah.
And then he goes,
and he was shaking in front of my face.
He's serious,
he's serious.
He's this close to my face.
Why I shaking like this close and my friends,
everybody is already like almost dying,
laughing.
And then he says,
and then a moment he's perplexed by and I go,
I go to the neck and then he,
they always do this.
He said,
it says in there,
grab him.
And now he kept eye contact with me,
right.
And he grabbed,
she says,
I got
and you get through knees,
he gets back to contact with me and it stops,
you know,
so I look at him,
I go,
Nah,
you never did that.
Don't have all it.
I said,
you practiced this in the mirror and it looks really cool,
but you never did this.
You don't know.
His friends were like,
they were waiting for my reaction because they were in our,
you know,
this,
this guy was ha.
It was his glory.
And then when at the moment I said,
total bullshit.
I started talking and there's not a guy came to see,
you know,
he is,
he always actually professional fighters.
So the whole group left.
But the fact the,
the face,
the facial expression from all those guys,
they're all dressed the same.
Like these Khakis,
which shirt over the top,
all jewelry everywhere,
you know the,
those guys exactly.
Express the streets.
Karate guy.
His routine saves his life seven times,
you know,
and they tell me they extreme that you believe that crap.
It was the most insane thing I've ever seen.
And I did it.
And then here comes the boom you remember had but need to the face throwaway
stub,
victory dance.
You know,
and I that I told that the backstage camera for here,
it goes to them.
I said,
this is a true story.
Somebody told me this technique,
there's a lot of those knuckleheads,
right?
They'll street defense guys.
They're like fake karate guys.
And you know,
the worst part is they say,
yeah,
we cannot use it in the ring because it's way too dangerous.
I said,
well if you could kill somebody like this,
she can also not kill him.
Right.
I mean what?
I mean they kind of control that kind of control or you just,
a techniques are too lethal boss.
You know what I'm standing there like it's like dropping a nuclear explosion on
you.
You know what I'm saying?
The one inspiring shoulder.
Yeah.
I love those videos.
Like Kung Fu videos or grass at demonstrating techniques and how they're going
to work.
And have you seen the one where the old man who's got this class where he throws
like people and then a karate guy,
Pankratz guy comes in and beats the shit out of all the shit out of him.
Right,
right.
I mean,
you see him bleed.
He's,
he's seeing himself.
He cannot believe it.
It doesn't work.
He's trying.
The one guy,
he does take it to get to get the guy goes,
yeah.
He goes and he makes a somersault and he falls under ground.
It's almost like he believed his own bullshit.
Right.
What are these guys doing?
They're all faking it.
They know they are,
but they're probably,
it's like mass hypnosis or mass hysteria,
you know,
like cult behavior.
They get locked into believing.
Like I remember when I was in my,
my taekwondo school was not like cultish in the sense,
like they,
nobody had to do anything crazy.
They didn't try to get your money or get you to leave your family or anything
like that.
But the devotion that some people had towards the instructor was a pretty crazy,
it's amazing and they didn't exploit it,
but if someone did exploited,
you could see that how they could get some weak people that would really fall
into it.
It's,
it's sort of a disturbing aspect of martial arts that I,
one of the things that I really loved about Brazilian Jujitsu was that you
didn't kind of see that you didn't see like all the bowing.
It was more like friendly.
Like when I trained with the Machados like,
hey my friend,
how are you?
And it was much once they show you the techniques,
but they're very friendly and more,
more like,
like,
you know,
they don't try to place themselves above anyone.
There's no master though,
because
they're going to let you know that it is really effective right there and there
on the respect that you get from them.
You'll,
they'll earn it just by being amazing.
But it's because they're good.
All the other guys,
she'll preach and talk about it like that.
They're not good.
They suck.
Like every guy who tells me that he is unbelievable,
but he never fought.
It's full of Shit.
Well,
you know how many times indeed it's not possible.
You never,
he will not know if he can do it under pressure.
He will not.
It's amazing.
Do you know when you guys have told me though that they could never lose?
I never lose money.
You don't know about my mentality.
I'm in Palatine yelling,
get choked.
I'm like an animal,
Bro.
I'm a go my go blank and then yeah,
that's fine.
It's done dropping.
I go blank.
Get A,
she'd only anything,
right?
That's the easiest.
I hadn't named Jess coming into my class one time.
I,
I'm no kidding.
There's a guy walking in with the stash glasses and a big belly and a blue blue
chemo knows and they came in my NGO in Holland and he walked in,
there was six girls following him.
It was like a cult.
It was the weirdest thing ever.
And later on we find out he could even like a pushups.
It was like bizarre.
And every time when I was show something,
they would say something like one time,
you know,
uh,
I had an arm bar and this girl says,
oh,
we would bite and the leg,
you know,
so I started slowly but surely,
I figure I'm not gonna say anything,
but then,
you know,
it kept going,
kept going and have somebody in a rear naked choke.
And I said,
what's up and explaining as she goes to somebody else.
She says,
we were Boogie.
I said,
no.
And I go,
oh,
excuse me,
what was that?
And she said,
we will poke your eyes out right now.
I said,
wow,
let's find out.
I mean,
I'm going to try this with you.
Is that cool?
Yeah.
She goes,
let's go sit down.
I said,
put my arm around her neck.
okay.
In three seconds I'm going to go,
if you touch my,
I'm going to break your neck.
Okay,
let's go.
She goes,
well,
what?
Well,
what did she say?
I said,
in three seconds we're going to go and we'll count down.
You come,
come near to my fucking,
I'm going to break your neck.
Okay.
I should have been there.
What do you,
what do you mean?
I said,
okay.
You know what?
Uh,
normally when somebody touches my eye,
you think I'm going to go,
oh no,
I'm going to go to just of my idol and I'm going to go.
Then my eye hurts.
That faith's was awesome.
Never,
never fuck with somebody who has a dominant position over you.
Can I have you in an arm bar and you buy my calf gas?
What's going to break at that moment is the most idiot thing that people
actually believe that if you put a finger in my oven,
even of life and death situation,
I'm going to let go of to choke.
Yeah.
Really.
You know are going to snap the neck first and I'm going to let go to choke.
People don't understand how quick you go.
Unconscious like,
well,
if someone has a rear naked choke on you,
especially if you don't really know defense.
He haven't been choked a lot before.
You don't know how to relax.
You don't know how to talk and do,
you know all hard.
It is to poke and I
get very hard.
It's very hard.
I squeezed my,
I put my,
my I against your,
the back of your neck,
back of your head.
Now when you're used to doing boss Wooten is fighting in a sport type situation
where you got rules,
see out in the street there are no rules,
you know,
and like I cannot fight without rules to I guess to have,
I still only I can do it better,
more accurate as well.
I used to do this,
well I do this radio show,
I won't name the guy,
but there was a guy that they had as their body guard and he's a fucking total
bullshit artist and he was fucking dude with videos doing nunchucks and shit.
It was so stupid bastard poke opie and Anthony Show and we were on the show once
and this,
I mean I'm fine,
you know,
you do whatever you want,
but as soon as you're on the air and you're represented,
you know,
you,
I gotta I gotta tell the truth.
You're on the fucking radio now and people are going listen to you and if I let
you get away with some nonsense and not a not me man,
some young kid could be listening to that and they want to start a martial art
and they get sucked into doing a stupid fucking cretes street karate classes.
Cause,
and I go,
listen,
it's real simple.
The shit that works on trained killers is the best shit.
Yeah.
You don't see Anderson Silva,
you know,
practicing.
I pokes and fucking,
although I pokes a pretty fucking successful,
you don't see him doing the,
you know,
a death touch and fucking,
pressure point.
Yup.
Uh,
attacks.
That shit doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
I said on an on camera,
we had an email from somebody who said that his monster could put point
pressures.
They could knock you out.
I got a great story,
but there's also with Amir,
anyway,
I'd looked into gamma.
I said,
okay,
anybody in America you're watching right now,
if you have a person who gets,
who says that he can knock me out with a punch like it just pressing somewhere.
We invite him,
we pay him,
we pay his trip,
he can come on the show,
he can do it on camera on me.
He can knock me out.
I said,
it's a no lose situation for me because if it works,
I'm signing up to do that stuff.
But I tell you it's not going to work.
We had this guy but a,
you know a mirror Pareto.
You know most of where my buddy,
we see these guys on stage and the touch guys,
right?
So one guy goes,
this,
this was,
the person has this.
They just fall back.
And then the guy said,
did you see his eyes roll back in his skill?
That means you was out for real.
So I'd go to America.
This is going to be fun.
Why is this so these guys,
they come walking down after the set.
I said,
okay,
do it do to me.
I want you to do it to me.
You wanted him to know couch.
He said,
are you sure about that?
I still do it to me.
I,
you know,
I want to know how to feel.
And he goes,
you know what,
I could actually,
uh,
I got something better.
So we already steered away from it,
right?
So he says,
uh,
let me show you this.
And he walks over to his body,
they start talking to each other and then he walks away and in the corner he
stands like this.
Huh?
I mean crazy.
Hiney run stores,
his friend,
and he goes like this fuck.
And a midair.
He stops and he flies on the ground.
So he threw like Kung Fu console,
hence I didn't touch him,
doesn't touch him.
I go,
dude,
I'm sold.
Do that to me.
Right.
I'm going to attack you right now.
So I'm going to the Kona.
And he goes,
yeah,
but you have to be a really angry.
I said,
excuse me,
you really angry or otherwise it won't work.
I say,
your friend just did it right?
I said,
I think I can better act then your friend.
Don't worry.
I'll be in the zone,
you know,
will he says,
no,
because if,
if you're not real angry,
it doesn't work.
It needs to be that balance.
So I know it was this way out.
So I walked over to him and I'm standing like this.
I say kick me into pills and he says,
what?
I say kick me.
I'm going to go really fucking pissed.
He did want to do it.
Needless to say,
I mean,
but they're idiots that truly believe that is true.
Well,
it's so easy to take someone who doesn't know anything like it was a student and
trick them like that and be a con man like that.
And you know what the worst thing is?
There's teachers out there,
they give you a false sense of security and then you,
they teach you how to defend a knife,
you know,
grabbing the wrist.
I mean,
never did.
I mean it's so dangerous.
Knife is dangerous than a gun on a short distance.
At least they teach them the wrong way.
And then something happens on the street.
Somebody pulls a knife and he goes to his buddy,
dude,
it's that bag.
I got it.
Yeah.
You know,
and they get killed.
Eddie Bravo has a crazy story about that guy's fault.
It's theirs.
Okay.